oh yeah better now so let's talk about
ketchup it's sabab I'm filling feature
and slowly how excited were you to give
your fans new music especially at this
time yeah
my sister and I we've been extremely
excited to just put out new music we
finished our album I think like late
October November we finished our project
and you know we created visuals for it
and we're just excited to share with the
world because we've been holding on to
its own ear and due to our hearts and we
can't wait to continue to put out more
and we're really happy to catch up we've
always been huge fans of suede Lee and
you know to do such a fun song with him
we're really happy about that
[Music]
this song is about it's like a
tit-for-tat love song you know it's a
little bit about how somebody does
something to you that hurts your
feelings you're gonna do something back
to them there it's their feelings it's
like drama song so it's okay so this is
a new sound we've watched you to evolve
from sugar symphony to your last album
The Kids Are Alright and now we have
ungodly hour
so what version of Chloe and Halle are
we getting on this new album so our new
album ungodly hour is definitely a deep
dive into our diary into all of our
feelings our secrets our insecurities we
were inspired with the title ungodly
hour because during those hours in the
middle of the night when your love when
your sleepless at 2:00 3:00 a.m. it's
like those are the moments where you
really self reflect where you're one
with yourself and your insecurities
you're thinking about what you're doing
the next day you're thinking about your
life purpose all of these feelings are
coming up and we feel like this album
just is really a big melting pot of all
of those feelings so we were so excited
to finally just give our fans this too
so that they could digest it and
actually come into our diary and see
what we're feeling are we gonna get more
of that because you were growing up to
like y'all were growing up so it's gonna
be more of like grown and sexy vibes
with the visuals and all of that you
know it's definitely more grown and sexy
we really loved creating this album
because we got to tap into our womanhood
and that was really exciting and so much
fun and we get to be flirty and really
share what's on our minds and you know
not have to withhold what we really want
to say so that's really fun the kids all
right it's a great time for us because
we were becoming into our own as you
know young kids growing into young women
but now that we are becoming more
confident in ourselves we're like okay
we can really own this and that's what
exactly ours about it's okay not being
perfect all the time
I love that when can we actually get
album you said you finished it in
October I heard some reports it was
gonna be made that still still the goal
oh actually will be announced very very
soon okay I want everybody to look out
halli the Little Mermaid Congrats first
of all we were screaming around often
okay so we know we know that the film
was supposed to start filming early 2020
what's the update with that yes well
just like everybody else I mean the
whole world is kind of one pause I was
in London at the beginning of the year
and about to start filming and of course
this pandemic has caused everybody to
kind of slow down and I actually
welcomed it because I was really missing
my sister bigger humans here in LA I was
in London so I was happy to get back to
her and you know I'm just so very
excited for when we start back again
it's just really coming together
I just feel honored every day to even
think about it or talk about it I'm like
look back that's really happening do you
think the cast will change at all
because of the schedule change no not at
all everybody's so beautiful humans
excited now and everybody it's already
like the family are we gonna get
original music from you too on the
soundtrack well Chloe you have the
Georgetown project with Academy Award
winners Russell Crowe what was that
experience like for you what he teased
oh wow that experience is really fun be
shot like around November December time
in Wilmington North Carolina and it's
like a horror film like sophisticated
horror film and I'm like the biggest
scaredy-cat there is but the script was
just so beautifully written I had to do
it and I learned so much by being around
such incredible actors and I'm really
happy I was able to be a part of it I
can't wait for it to come out so I've
always wanted to ask an actress or an
actor in a horror film do you actually
get scared
shooting like are there moments where
you're like oh not while shooting okay
like in between each take everyone would
bust out laughing and energy that was
really positive and I'm like very
spiritual and like keeping my energy
sacred and clean so I was like oh yeah I
didn't get scared while filming it I
know I'm gonna get scared while watching
the movie because it's pretty good doing
that
aren't you gonna know when things are
coming okay well a lot of fans are
waiting for grown --is-- to come back
the mid-season finale happened but when
are we gonna get it when are we gonna
finish out the season I believe like
this summer has yet to air and yeah like
it's like the summer finale but you all
I finish filming already
oh yeah okay do you have any a message
for your fans just any message of hope
that you want to share with them right
now
Wow well definitely during this time
what's helped me is reminding myself
that I have to have patient easy and
that it's okay like it's okay that life
is slowing down right now the world
obviously needed this from some reason
and just to be patient with yourself and
to not know be too hard on yourself as
well these times are very uncertain so
everybody is always thinking about the
future and what you're gonna do but if
you just take the time to be grateful
and ground yourself for the things that
you have and your health and you really
realize that it's okay yeah for sure
anything from you Chloe you know this
during this moment my gratitude is just
kind of gone through the roof because
I'm just grateful to be with my family
right now in this moment and all of the
little things that I used to care and
think about and overthink about suddenly
don't seem to matter because I'm safe
and I'm healthy and so my heart goes out
to all of the health care workers you
know there are true heroes right now
[Music]